[Music]
has anyone in this room come across that
tick-tock with a big baby
oh damn big-ass baby I thought that [ __ ]
was fake
have you known I thought Tycho was a big
baby we do a Tech Talk video TIFF has
this tickled energy in the very start of
it tickle hi how is it that you don't
have a tick tock I do I open it because
you don't of losing my the rest of my
year
you love it oh wait you browse on tick
tock without an account no well I did
before but not you can but I don't use
it I don't know blowed now the only way
that I come across tick tock videos is
because of my Twitter or Instagram
that's the only way I'll see you got a
sec because I'm really scared of myself
and opening that app just losing myself
cause of the nudity no because it's just
so addicting there's nudity I take that
no I just made that up I thought there's
only Twitter there's a lot of Christian
tick tock yeah quite the opposite yeah
yeah I found this one guy who's like
Jesus booking rules he's like you can
swear it's okay to swear because God
loves you anyway and I was like in
height it's a better attitude than some
of the cats I knew growing up Steve have
you seen this big baby video I know I'm
talking huge I think I might have seen
it is it a big baby with lots of
wrinkles
oh yeah use fat baby
he's like her Isaac in baby form it was
a white baby he's like Isaac's eyes but
a baby size wow you're a man baby I will
show you this video it's kind of scary
it's baby Huey in real life okay here we
go oh my god
[Music]
CGT though that guy's pretty big baby I
really need it later Leo baby powder
when he jumps wow he has the body of a
playground holy the baby powder did come
out well he's just like a fat kid things
like a ten-year-old it's like it looks
like a baby though that's like Pau Gasol
is a baby whose dad basketball players
okay so right off the bat first of all
it this is not an infant like a lot of
people on the internet assumed this
little boy is three years old named
Gavin that's still a big [ __ ]
three-year-old I wear diapers then at
three oh you still wear diapers like the
limit yeah
[Laughter]
like usually three it's like kind of
already on the old side of wearing
diapers but if you're a four not
supposed to wear diapers for sure yeah
they're supposed to be out of diapers by
two-and-a-half oh really oh yeah big
time it's like it's considered scary if
they're still in diapers after to go let
you out of it because there are some
kids like for example um some cousins of
mine in Mexico like they'll leave on
diapers took like way old and then it
ends up like kind of deforming their
legs oh well like causing the thighs to
like have like kind of like a like a
loop-the-loop bowlegged yeah bully is
that the thigh got that all the girls
want no just wait it's called diaper
look
yeah diaper League oh no no no she
agreed with you though they are
[Music]
my precious diet you know and then still
they end up having to go to the I forgot
the ER no no the FBI interest yeah
that's a little foot doctor
yeah the foot talk to the Tigers and
then they have to get the towel out your
shoes okay tell that Mexican Crocs you
buy that whole lockers hello Joe the
Mexico's greatest basketball player at
the TV show from Mexico from like the
80s or something and anyway this is it's
a TV show
the point is I thought 70s is the best
Mexican TV period okay why did you
reference it as that name because that's
kind of what they reference those shoes
because they're these big blocky
orthopedic shoes like to correct the the
bowlegged myth oh that's a common like
thing that kids have in Mexico yeah oh
wow as far as I know I don't I can't
speak for all in my travel or chose I
mean did that bleed over today today's
fashion trends everyone's Feliz in China
oh yeah maybe everyone's trying to get
rid of their thigh gaps but no these
there are these special shoes that in
Mexico are you like hey I like your luck
shows just kind of short no cuz people
don't usually like these shoes are
embarrassing it's like oh like those
like the headgear oh oh I had to wear
those when I had my I had an ingrown
toenail and and we've had a headgear
because yet in grunt but I have word
headgear when I used to rollerblade did
you have it at the same time because
that's a really bad come to know it's
not good thank you
but yeah dude I had an ingrown toenail
and then they had to rip that [ __ ] out
of there it was nuts
and then I had to wear this special shoe
today sucked yeah oh don't worry for
like oh no just give you a tow more
space yeah yeah yeah so the toenail
could start growing straighter I think
it was cuz it pain actually they didn't
hear of like flip-flops or like slides
he said he that he didn't recommend
those he recommended this the most
amount of space well cuz it's cuz you
can slide around or whatever the [ __ ]
protected uh-huh yeah and especially me
because I don't like flip-flops they
don't work good on my feet
oh you gotta wear it more often because
it the thong part right anyway back to
this big baby so people have been
[ __ ] brutal on Twitter and like the
comments or wild so for example like
this one said well it being so mean to a
baby I'm not tweeting anything mean
about the big baby I'm not trying to get
my ass kicked this other one that's kind
of mild this other one stop people
posting insanely mean things about a big
baby
like just ridiculously dark to say
things like that about an innocent human
infant then I saw it and yeah I get it
the big-ass baby I mean not a baby but
that's a big-ass shock
that's still a big three-year-old man
for sure but what are they saying though
that's like we keep saying that's a
big-ass baby that's a big-ass baby sex
[ __ ] this little baby literally saying
things like this is the most repulsive
thing I've ever seen in my recipe watch
why yeah there's people that are like
this is [ __ ] gross I can't believe
someone like that exists in this like
like assault someone should reply Bob do
you mean that's just a big baby like an
elephant yeah with a picture of Bart in
a diaper and see how they feel about
that Wow who let this baby get tattoos
there's a whole youtube video about oh
yeah I'm surprised Fox didn't do an
article about how this is [ __ ] up
because nobody should be dancing during
this pandemic always loved that [ __ ]
yeah there's a [ __ ] like big baby we
ended up being a meme so there's like a
whole bunch of photos and like
references like for example this one
here I just pulled it up on Twitter
that's like big baby
age 14 trying to get his revenge for all
the memes and like just referencing like
other things in in pop culture or
whatever and so the mom of this child's
got interviewed and she's just saying
like it's just so cruel that things
people are saying like he's just an
innocent baby and yes were they
interviewing her kneecap she's at all
can you imagine just like popping that
thing out [ __ ] destroy the vaginas so
she said came out that size exactly like
he was a normal sized infant like he was
6 pounds with 15 ounces or something
okay
yeah that's normal yeah as normal and so
she but she did say that on both sides
of the family that there are really tall
men like big boned people so because the
dad just looks regular yeah cuz if the
dad was huge
then it would make the baby look small
yes I was a 10-pound baby
don't tell Nicky why why not tell how
come don't tell me she has to give birth
to his children oh we were ten pound
baby ten pounds what's the way it was
the average eight without pain meds bro
what why would she do such a thing
she didn't whine all of those you know
you're the first baby oh I had a
smoother ride I do hear that when the
other ones you get stretched out a
little bit more easier oh the second
time around
yeah like the cervix has already been
expanded even for like particular like
IUDs and stuff they recommend women who
have had a child because their cervix
has already been like yeah and the late
and the labor gets shorter and shorter
and shorter easily that's what I heard
too is that the time to push the baby
out or the yeah yeah I mean uh what did
the Seth Meyers he talked about when he
had his kid his first kid came out in
the taxi ride on the route to the
hospital so the second time they were
like okay we're gonna prepare we're
gonna get the baby bag ready so as soon
as you feel it we're out of here right
and as soon as they got into the lobby
of their like their the place they lived
in the baby popped right out go away Wow
the baby is here he's like yeah I'm
calling the taxi and then she's like no
the baby's here and she's like oh I'm
just shopping out her god
she doesn't know how to hold it don't
wear more pants it was very simple for
lucky she probably didn't feel anything
yeah but the unfortunate thing was that
her vagina was just out for the entire
public to see in the lobby she was like
I've never been closer to my doorman
unto that was everyone huddled around
helping out and [ __ ] yes I was just
staring at this vagina with this baby
coming it's not a vagina does not look
appealing when the baby's coming out of
it no I will complain to my building
manager I had to see that on that
neighbor look everyone's in the hallway
like help it on and I'm like what's that
smell this is not a baby delivery room
who wet the floor yeah yeah there's got
to be another word for Karen but the guy
like a bob or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah the guy Karen guys like for example
the dad I had his son and then he was
like calling the cops on that oh yeah on
the guy in his apartment complex they
all get nicknames yeah I do
I think Richard dick dick yeah Bradley
Bradley what I think Bradley I think a
surfer or some someone that's into sport
is it sound way too cool yeah they're
too chill they're too chill yeah Bradley
is cool Bradley could [ __ ] your
girlfriend too we got to be careful
about the Bradley yes yes Jeff I think
Jeff Jeff yeah [ __ ] Jeff yeah Jeff Jeff
yeah I'm gonna mean Jeff's
[Music]
you
[Music]